abc's role charter i am required to
determine a funding settlement for the
level of the license fee for a period of
at least five years from the 1st of
april 2022
i am legally required to make my
determination as far in advance of april
as possible
i'd also like to highlight that this
year the license fee settlement has
featured s4c prominently for the first
time
in line with the recommendation from the
independent review as s of s
s4c completed in 2018
the license fee will be the sole source
of public funding for s4c
negotiations back in november 2020
they began back in november 2020 and
both i and my predecessor have met with
bbc with the bbc on several occasions
during this period to discuss the
settlement
as part of those negotiations the
charter requires that i assess both the
bbc's commercial income and activities
and the level of funding required so the
bbc can effectively fulfill its mission
and public purposes
in addition this government has set out
our own relevant factors to consider
during the charter review in 2015-16
evasion commercial income household
growth and industry costs
mr speaker as the prime minister has
said the bbc is a great institution
it has a unique place in our current
cultural heritage
and beyond our shores the bbc broadcasts
our values and identities all over the
world reaching hundreds of millions
every day
likewise the welsh broadcaster s4c plays
a unique and critical role in promoting
the welsh language and in supporting our
wider public service broadcasting
landscape
however mr speaker
in reaching this settlement i had to be
realistic about the economic situation
facing households up and down the
country
the global cost of living is rising
and this government is committed to
supporting families as much as possible
during these difficult times
given that climate
we had to think very carefully about
imposing potential increase on the tv
license
particularly given that any increase
would expose families to the potential
threat of bailiffs knocking on their
door or criminal prosecution
when it comes to monthly bills this is
one of the few direct levers that we
have in our control as a government
and in the end mr speaker we simply
could not justify putting extra pressure
on the wallets of hard-working
households
every
organization
around the world is facing the challenge
of inflation
i simply do not believe that those
responsible for setting household bills
should instinctively reach into the
pockets of families across the country
for just a little more every year to
cover those costs
so today i am announcing that the
license field fee will be frozen for the
next two years
and that it will rise in line with
inflation for the following four years
the bbc wanted the fee to rise to over
180 pounds by the end of this settlement
instead it will remain fixed at 159
pounds until april 2024
that's more money in the pockets of
pensioners in the pockets of families
who are struggling to make ends meet
mr speaker we are supporting households
at a time when they need that support
the most
and this settlement sends
an important message about keeping costs
down while also giving the bbc what it
needs to deliver on its remit
this approach to funding will be the
same for the bbc and for s4c
however
i can also announce that s4c will
receive an additional 7.5 million pounds
per annum funding from 2022 to support
the development of their digital
offering
this is a nine percent increase for s4c
following five years of frozen funding
mr speaker we believe that this is a
first settlement for the bbc
it is the first settlement for s4c and
most importantly it's the first
settlement for licensed fee players
across the united kingdom
and let's not forget the bbc will
continue to receive billions in annual
public funding allowance allowing it to
deliver its mission and public purposes
and to continue doing what it does best
and to support the bbc even further in
what is a fast changing broadcasting
landscape the government will more than
double the borrowing limit of the bbc's
commercial arm to 750 million pounds
this will enable the bbc to access
private finance as it pursues an
ambitious commercial growth strategy
boosting investment in the creative
economy across the uk
but as tim davies said in his first
speech as director general of the
corporation the bbc must be a simpler
leaner organization that offers better
value to licensed fee payers and we
agree with this
ultimately the settlement strikes the
right balance between protecting
households and allowing broadcaster to
deliver their vital public
responsibilities
whilst also encouraging them to make
further savings and efficiencies
mr speaker the license fee settlement is
only one step in our roadmap for reform
of the bbc
in the last few months i've made it
clear that the bbc needs to address
issues around impartiality and
groupthink
those problems were highlighted
definitively by the recent sarota review
and the bbc's own leadership rightly
recognized those findings in full and
committed to deliver all of the reviews
recommendations in its 10-point action
plan on impartiality and editorial
standards
and i have had constructive discussions
with the bbc about these issues in
recent months
but the bbc now needs to put those words
into action
it needs to convince the british public
that those changes are in fact being
made and to provide regular and
transparent outcounts of its progress
we will shortly begin the midterm review
of the bbc's charter which will consider
the overall governance and regulation of
the bbc and a key part of that review
will look at whether the bbc's action
plan on impartiality has in fact
materially contributed to improving the
internal governance of the organization
but it's also time to look further into
the future
mr speaker as any serious commentator
will tell you the broadcasting landscape
has changed beyond all recognition over
the past decade
we're living in a world of streaming
giants of on demand and on pay-per-view
and smart tvs technology is changing
everything
97
of homes already have super fast
broadband
a family in cambria can stream five
different movies in five different rooms
in its house at any one time and our
gigabit rollout is transforming those
networks even further
over 65 of uk households now have access
to the fastest connection on the planet
as the tech has changed so have audience
habits
particularly amongst younger viewers
so it's time to begin asking those
really serious questions about the
long-term funding model of the bbc and
whether a mandatory licence fee with
criminal penalties for individual
households is still appropriate
as we have said before we will therefore
undertake a review of the overall
license beam model and those discussions
will begin shortly
mr speaker the bbc has been entertaining
and informing us for a hundred years and
i wanted to continue to thrive and be a
global beacon in the uk and in the
decades to come
but this is
2022 not
1922.
we need a bbc that is forward-looking
and ready to meet the challenges of
modern broadcasting
a bbc that can continue to engage the
british public and that commands the
support from across the breadth of the
uk
not just the london bubble
a bbc that can thrive alongside netflix
and amazon prime and all of its other
challenges which attract younger viewers
the license fee settlement represents a
significant step in that journey and in
our wider reform of the bbc
i look forward to continuing working
with the bbc and others across the
industry over the coming years to secure
the future of these vital british
services i commend this statement to the
house